this is 45 year old Tim Friede from
Wisconsin and he's about to let this
snake bite his arm why this is a black
mamba snake one of the most venomous
deadly snakes on the planet
Black Mamba venom contains a very potent
neurotoxin that interferes with the
body's ability to signal through the
nervous system it can affect the way you
breathe it can make your heart stop
beating it can even affect your liver
and your kidneys all very good reasons
not to do this twice nice I can't
believe this guy was Betty buy a black
mamba and he survived what's his secret
there is as proof that thankfully we met
Tim and his collection of snakes to find
out how his slithery obsession began
wait first white I was I believe five
years old as a kid from the garter snake
and at that point it's kind of just some
snakes but how does he survive this
black mamba bite Tim is essentially a
walking science experiment for the past
few years tim has been exposing himself
repeatedly to snake venom by actually
injecting dilute amounts of it into his
body is not enough to kill him but it is
enough for his immune system to
recognize there's something dangerous
here and this causes his body to mount
an immune response and generate
antibodies which were little molecules
that bind to the toxins and neutralize
them now if you bitten by a snake like
this in normal circumstances you're
never gonna have enough of these
antibodies in your system to do anything
about it but in Tim's case because he's
been building these up in his system
over time he's got a store basically so
when he gets bitten by the snake his
body's got enough of these antibodies to
immediately go out there and neutralize
that venom Tim is doing something very
crazy to my point of view but on the
other hand it does kind of serve a
purpose usually a normal person would
never inject themselves with venom now
we can learn how the body can deal with
it at first I was I was scared to death
because you don't know if it's gonna
work you run that risk nowadays after
120 bites and up to 400 and Jackson's
I've become relaxed with it
now for those of you watching the clip
and concerned about the welfare of the
snake the snake is fine it was being
handled correctly and it was basically
behaving in exactly the same way it
would at any time it strikes okay but
being bitten by a snake is still
dangerous the danger here and the reason
that scientists don't recommend you do
this is that in exposing himself
repeatedly to Black Mamba venom Tim
could actually develop an allergy and
then that snake bite could cause him to
go into anaphylactic shock and die and
when it comes to a black mamba thanks
but no thanks